what up guys welcome to the just hurry
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
new podcast called Pearl daily where I
go over this week's treachery
and honestly just Abominations that I've
seen in the news before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification Bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos also guys if you're tired of
being a whale sign up for my program
whale watchers on patreon where a group
of women come together and try to lose
weight and also become better wives
um so today what are we going to talk
about so to start Kiki Palmer
so Kiki Palmer is an actress and I
believe
I don't I don't know too much about her
I think she was in girls trip and like
some other
I don't know she's some actress lady
and she went to an Oscar concert now I
get it okay
I love shimmying I love you know busting
a move I like listening to music so I
get it I don't see a problem with women
going to a concert so I've heard that
Twitter has been an uproar about her at
this concert being that she has a
boyfriend and she has a a kid let's see
how she acted at this concert
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
can you imagine if that was your mom can
you guys imagine
your mother just you're like oh I want
to see how old is I know Kiki Palmer has
a kid so she has a newborn she's 29
years old can you imagine you know you
you've seen those old scrapbooks of your
parents when they first got married
right do you guys do your parents have
one I don't know but I'll look at like
old pictures my mom and dad hanging out
together having a good time can you
imagine then you see your mother you're
like flipping through okay and boom your
mom's ass is on the picture at an usher
concert
and now
your memories of like them first married
is your mother grinding on another man
now I don't know if women understand how
crazy this is you know what Kiki do your
thing at like you know what if we'll
give you a pass 16 17. like the men knew
that the women maybe would do some crazy
[__] back in the day but they're like
they'll put that away when we when we
have children and you become a wife no
now now we have wives where we don't
even like you can't even tell based on
how they act if they're in a
relationship or not so let's see I guess
her man had something to say about this
Tiki Palmer's boyfriend oh shames her
for the outfit she wore to the Usher
concert it's the outfit though dot dot
dot you're a mom this man is being
dragged on the internet for basically
asking please don't wear a thong to an
usher concert now the top comment says
get a new boyfriend sis the idea that
once women give birth the only identity
they're allowed to have is Mother and
matronly it is so harmful and isolates
tons of mothers to the point that they
dead Emoji people are people as long as
they aren't hurting anyone and she's not
let them be trouble in Paradise already
why are men so jealous of women who are
more successful and popular than them
the next one every woman in this thread
is clowning him or single or is either
single not married or fat and ugly yes
yes I agree with that guy so we're in a
society
where we literally cannot tell the
difference between wives and hookers
because look at her her outfit I
literally if you saw her at three in the
morning in a rough area in like a city
but
maybe in Vegas I know they got hella
hookers in Vegas could you could we pull
up the outfit again can we just pull up
the outfit guys I just wanna as a group
could you maybe like would you
understand if that was a hooker in a
thong yeah you might mistake her like
this is the level of wives and the women
are saying well yeah this is the picture
so not only that then she posts another
picture in this outfit
dressed like a hooker now this is the
problem we have modern women that have
nothing else to offer
except for their looks when their looks
start to fade and go older women would
say you know what you might need to act
a little different you're supposed to
move different you're a mom now like
guys I don't think it's crazy
that we don't do the same thing at 16
that we do at 30. and Men know this like
the guys will go a bit crazy at 16.
they're they're horsing around doing
whatever and at 30 they're like you know
what I got a kid I can't you know go out
do the crazy things I used to but women
today
their teenage years it's like the the
second they become attractive like 15 16
they mentally stay that age until 45
nowadays we have the worst generation of
wives and mothers like guys it is no
wonder men are walking away from
Marriage when they look at the marriage
Market they're like I want a wife where
do I buy one and this is what they get
a a wife that looks like a hooker
like guys
yes you are supposed to lose a part of
yourself when you're getting when you
get married you are not supposed to act
the same way you did when you were
single and if you think this is crazy
maybe the marriage marriage and children
just isn't for you I don't think she's
actually married I think she's a
boyfriend but you guys get the gist you
get the gist so let's talk about the
next wife and mother let's talk about
Kim Kardashian now for those of you that
don't know I don't know how you can be
an American and not know who Kim
Kardashian is but Kim Kardashian is a
billionaire or close to it right she has
been in social media for you know our
entire lives basically and about 10 15
years ago she married Kanye West so
Kanye and Kim went public with their
romance in 2012. so they started dating
in 2012 this is over 10 years ago
recently um about a year ago year and a
half they announced their divorce
now you know a lot of people would label
Kim Carr or Kanye as crazy
okay and you know maybe maybe he he
maybe is a bit eccentric whatever but
Kim Kardashian
she had like a new boyfriend immediately
after all this whatever whatever so they
moved on whatever
and in the new
um series
Kim talks about her divorce why don't we
bring up the clip you're okay not okay
it's so different than the person that I
married I just I just can't that's who I
loved and that's who I remember
I'll do anything to get that person back
this is something I hear so often on the
show they'll be like Pearl Pearl how do
you know the man won't just switch up
when we're married and this is what I
say is that oftentimes women will marry
a man and he shows you exactly who he is
and then women want to whine later about
their choices so what happened
um Kim marries Kanye and towards the end
of the relationship a big stress was
Kanye being very eccentric he would post
tweets about their marriage and they
were very public that this was a very
hard time in their marriage so
how could he just switch up and publicly
blast out all their information Kanye
was never eccentric except roll the clip
with the breach of three levees
protecting New Orleans the landscape of
the city has changed dramatically
tragically and perhaps irreversibly
there's now over 25 feet of water where
there was one city streets and thriving
neighborhoods
I hate the way they betray us and the
media if you see a black family it says
they're looting see a white family and
says they're looking for food and you
know it's been five days because most of
the people
are black and even for me to complain
about I would be a hypocrite because
I've tried to turn away from the Teacher
TV because it's too hard to watch I've
even been shopping before even giving a
donation so now I'm calling my business
manager right now to see what's what is
the biggest amount I can give and and
just to imagine if I was if I was down
there and those are those are my people
down as anybody out there that wants to
do anything that we can help with with
the setup the way America is set up to
help the um uh the poor the the black
people the uh the less well-off as slow
as possible I mean this is Red Cross is
doing everything they can we already
realized a lot of the people that could
help r at War right now fighting another
way and they they've given them
permission to go down and shoot us
and subtle but in even many ways more
profoundly devastating is the lasting
damage to the survivor's will to rebuild
and remain in the area the destruction
of the spirit of the people of Southern
Louisiana and Mississippi may end up
being the most tragic loss of all George
Bush doesn't care about black people
that was Kanye West pull the next clip
pull the next clip
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm really happy for you I'm let you
finish but Beyonce had one of the best
videos of all time
one of the best videos of all time
this is what I mean
when women will pick a guy with certain
traits and qualities this is a dad on
Kanye you guys know I am a big yay fan I
think he's hilarious but if you're gonna
date a guy like that you know what
you're getting yourself into he's always
been eccentric he's always been the type
to just say it how it is publicly okay
so am I are we shocked are we shocked
that he does crazy stuff later when he's
always done crazy stuff but this is what
I mean women will pick a guy it will be
very obvious the type of guy he is and
then they will whine and complain about
the outcome and then break up their
family after they get the kids
so this is why I have no sympathy this
is why I have no sympathy um nobody's
perfect everybody has pros and cons of
them and you should just know the type
of guy you're dealing with and if you
can't pick for yourself I would find you
know a brother uncle or father because
as women we just pick stupidly they can
help us okay but that's the crazy thing
it's like women will be with the most
world-renowned Superstar of all time and
still complain like what does he not
have he's got money status Fame all the
things that modern women typically look
for and still
she's got to divorce him just like the
modern women way all right next up
Planned Parenthood comes forward and
says that virginity is a social
construct Planned Parenthood says the
idea of virginity comes from outdated
let's be real patriarchal ways of
thinking that hurts everybody there's
now a sign that says virginity is a
social construct money running dry needs
some new customers stop sexualizing
children you sick groomers okay these
comments are based disgusting you're
actually trying to drum up business see
and this is what I mean when I say
people are waking up to this stuff
people are starting to see the truth
because in all honesty modern women
women in general will just do anything
to get Purity back and I'm sorry I don't
care if you can reconstruct your entire
vagina it doesn't get rid of all of the
memories of you being a hoe okay I just
cannot deal with this Society where
women are trying to buy back Purity once
you're pure once your Purity is gone it
is gone and this is my issue deal with
the consequences don't try to shame men
for not wanting you don't try to shame
men and say oh virginity doesn't matter
because it does matter every study that
you could possibly see on body count
will tell you that it matters so stop
trying to shame men for liking what they
like guys you know you're either a
virgin or you're not a virgin
um and you know let's stop trying to
shame the men for wanting what they want
and maybe instead encourage the next
generation of women to wait what what do
female run organizations tend to lead
towards inclusion diversity
let's look at Planned Parenthood is that
is that men saying virginity is a social
construct or is that women saying that
virginity is a social construct is that
men encouraging Kiki to twerk on stage
in front of Usher while being a wife and
a mother or is that women and this is
the problem when women get too much
power in society guys we don't know what
to do with it like we we're horrible and
you know it's like they want to [__] on
me and say I'm just mean to women but I
just look at us collectively as a group
what type of wives and mothers are we as
a group are we known this generation
like the last hundred years are we known
for being really great wives mothers
that Foster community that raise
children well that keep the families
together all of the things that make
women valuable we have lost it used to
be something like looked up to to have a
bunch of kids get married and have a
family now you see that they're
projecting 50 percent of women won't
even have children
so what are we needed for in society
outside of reproduction you know now we
get into the workforce and we start
suing our employers we start suing our
employers we say we can do everything a
man can do let me work in a man's world
and then we Sue our employers
for harassment or whatever do you ever
see men suing for this type of stuff no
no it's women women do this and it's
really sad because the things that make
women beautiful and the things that make
us needed in society we are losing
because of the types of wives and
mothers we have become we have nannies
in daycare we have nannies and daycare
people raising our children so now we're
not even raising our own kids and it's
not like we're bringing in that much
money into the economy we make up over
55 percent of the population and what 30
percent was it of the GDP 35 of the GDP
I swear if women were banned from
working tomorrow
all the HR departments would close
I think GDP would go up because all of
the jobs we do
all of the jobs we do can be replaced by
a man quite easily the only the only and
and this is the problem is we have just
been told we are so special we do so
much and mothers give you life well dogs
give life too
and I'm not trying to downgrade women
but I do think we could use a little bit
of humility I don't think that's crazy
um but I don't know guys let me know
what you guys think in the comments
um don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification Bell
I'll talk to you guys next time